jérôme marty médecin généraliste et
président de l'union française pour
médecine kipre jérôme marty bonjour
merci d'être jouée en direct avec nous
sur e rt france on le voir le coc u19
poursuit sa progression dans l'hexagone
des mesures sanitaires plus strictes ont
été instaurées notamment ce week-end
avec le couvre-feu dans neuf métropoles
est-ce suffisant selon vous c'est
difficile à dire ce qui est certain
c'est que c'est une une mesure qui
devrait s'accompagner d'autres mesures
malheureusement on ne les voit pas trop
c'est à dire que la mesure principale
devrait être de changer notre politique
de tests vous savez cole est beaucoup
trop lent sur les tests même si elle
s'est améliorée même si maintenant il
faut deux à trois jours pour avoir un
diagnostic il faut incontestablement
accélérer cela il faut qu'on arrive à
avoir des tests rapides des autotests
pour que les gens puissent se tester
avant de rentrer dans certains lieux
si on veut relancer véritablement la vie
et l'économie et puis il faut qu'on soit
en capacité de faire du test prédictif
ou préventifs dans tous les lieux où
l'on sait que le virus a une propension
à circuler je pense aux ehpad je pense
au secteur sanitaire aux abattoirs je
pense aux aux écoles il faut qu'on soit
capable de tester très régulièrement
pour aller chercher le virus là où il
est et ne pas attendre qu'ils diffusent
et le pas en quelque sorte perdu du
temps à être proactifs plutôt créatif
alors nous sommes en plein en pleine
deuxième vague 1 est ce que aujourd'hui
le corps médical est mieux préparé à
affronter l'épidémie
quelle est la situation dans les
hôpitaux des moyens justement
on parle des lits de réanimation par
exemple la situation n'est pas du tout
la même que celle de mars et d'avril il
ya des il ya des points qui sont des
points positifs et puis malheureusement
il ya des points négatifs dans les
points positifs il ya le fait qu'on a
beaucoup appris de cette maladie que
l'on sait mieux l'appréhender que on
sait mieux éviter notamment des effets
secondaires ou des complications de
cette maladie on a changé les process de
traitement on a changé les molécules
utilisées et ça ça fait que on a un
temps de réanimation qui peut être un
peu moins long et puis moins de décès
mais parallèlement dans les points
négatifs il y à l'épuisement du
personnel le fait que tous les
personnels soignants qui s'occupe des
patients n'ont pas pu se reposer
puisqu'il a fallu ensuite prendre en
charge toutes les pathologies qui
avaient été mises en retard par la
poussée du pot vide et aujourd'hui on a
une nouvelle poussée du pauvre qui vient
s'ajouter à des patients peu qu'on est
en train de prendre paul est en train de
traiter et donc un épuisement du
personnel que ce soit d'ailleurs un
ville où que ce soit dans le secteur
hospitalier public ou privé donc ça
c'est dans les points négatifs
exactement comme dans les points
négatifs il ya le fait aujourd'hui le
virus et sur tout le territoire alors
que souvenez vous en mars et avril
ils n'étaient que donne deux régions en
gros alors les indicateurs sont en cas
dans le rouge dont on parle aujourd'hui
ces derniers jours environ trente mille
nouvelles contaminations plus ou moins
par jour et le taux de positivité des
tests qui est très haut et puis le
nombre de personnes placées en
réanimation également qui est en route
est ce là la donnée la plus inquiétante
à l'heure actuelle c'est
incontestablement elle a eu une des
données les plus les plus importantes
il ya celle d'aider effectivement des
entrées en rénovation pas ce que ça veut
dire qu'on peut se diriger vers une mise
en tension de nos services de
réanimation fort heureusement cette fois
on a mis à profit la particularité du
système de soins français qui est celle
d'avoir la foi et secteur privé au
secteur public
c'est que les cliniques sont mises à
contribution donc ça donne un petit peu
d'air en quelque sorte mais mais mais au
now na aussi un critère qui est très
inquiétant c'est le taux de positivité
vous en avait parlé il est posé là de
13%
et si vous regardez autour de vous
il n'y a pas une personne qui ne
connaissent pas un cas où un proche de
proches qui a été en contact d'un
contact ou d'un cas positif ça veut dire
que tout le monde ne connaît quelqu'un
qui a touché plus ou moins par la
maladie ce qui veut dire que le virus
circule beaucoup et qu'il y ait un
risque d'explosion un an ou un autre
comme ça s'est passé dans la région de
l'est mais dans plusieurs régions à la
fois c'est ce qui nous inquiète beaucoup
la campagne de vaccination contre la
grippe a été lancé la semaine dernière
un succès sans précédent pour une telle
campagne de vaccination est ce qu'il est
primordial aujourd'hui pour les français
d'aller se faire vacciner contre la
grippe pour éviter justement une double
épidémie ainsi ne pas engranger encore
plus les hôpitaux mais je sais pas si
c'est un succès parce que effectivement
on a beaucoup de gens qui sont
précipiter dans les pharmacies pour
retirer des vaccins à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui il est en rupture sur la
quasi totalité du territoire en tout cas
dans beaucoup de lieux
les pharmaciens nous alertent les
formations de terrain nous disant qu'ils
ne sont pas fournis notamment par leur
grossiste qui n'ont pas qu'ils ne
disposent pas des vaccins il ya eu du
retard au rona quantité de pharmaciens
qui nous disent voilà moi j'ai quatre ou
cinq ehpad à vacciner vous savez que ce
soit les gens âgés qui sont à risque
aussi cette pathologie et on a pris du
retard parce que il ya eu un
effondrement du du stock qui est liée à
la demande
donc on espère que les que les vaccins
vont revenir très vite dans les
pharmacies pour qu on puisse nous
médecins mais également les infirmières
et les pharmaciens vacciner la
population française
merci beaucoup jérôme marty d'avoir
réagi sur rtl ce matin je n'ai pas que
vous êtes médecin généraliste et
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre